okay either on purpose or accidentally
Donald Trump has admitted publicly for
the first time that I'm aware of that
Russia helped to get him elected Donald
Trump admitted this in a series of
tweets this morning responding to
yesterday's Robert Mulder statement
about the investigation and I I want
your help figuring this out because I
genuinely don't know whether Donald
Trump realizes that he admitted to
Russia helping to get him elected let's
take a look at the tweets and go right
to the source Trump tweeting this
morning Russia Russia Russia that's all
you heard at the beginning of this
witch-hunt hoax and now Russia has
disappeared because I had nothing to do
with Russia helping me to get elected it
was a crime that didn't exist and then
Donald Trump going on to say so now the
Dems and their partner the fake news
media say he fought back against this
phony crime that didn't exist this
horrendous false accusation etc etc but
again Donald Trump is denying not that
Russia helped him to win but that he had
anything to do with Russia helping him
to win this is finally an admission that
Russia helped Trump which Trump had
heretofore not admitted to and in fact
Trump denied it countless times
Trump denied that Russia helped Trump
denied that Russia preferred him over
Hillary and yet here he is admitting to
it as a foregone conclusion not even
arguing that Russia didn't help him to
win simply saying he wasn't involved
with it he didn't have anything to do
with it
Trump previously said Russian
interference if it existed had no effect
on the election results Trump previously
said at other times there was no
interference and then of course after
Donald Trump says I had nothing to do
with Russia helping me to get elected he
later backtracked less than an hour
later he was walking out to his
helicopter I believe at the White House
and he was asked about those tweets mr.
president you you just you seem to have
admitted that Russia did help you get a
lot
but you had nothing to do with it and
then he backtracked and said no no no
Russia didn't actually help me to get
elected another 180 degree flip on the
tweet from an hour earlier with which in
and of itself was 180 degree 80 degree
turnaround from his previous statements
that Russia didn't actually play a role
in helping to get him elected
so before we didn't have Trump on record
admitting that Russia helped get him
elected before Donald Trump tweeted that
he had nothing to do with Russia helping
to get him elected we only had the
pommes Anna Ford stuff and the Jeff
Sessions Russia lies and the Michael
Flynn Russia fiasco and the Russian
oligarch stuff and the money laundering
for Russians thing and the Trump Tower
meeting thing and the spilling of
secrets from Israel to a Russian spy
recruiter in the Oval Office thing and
the Russia giving stuff to WikiLeaks to
publish and help Trump thing and the
Russia if you're listening get those
emails and then Russia does actually go
in hack and get Hillary's emails we only
had all of that stuff and dozens of
other things before Donald Trump's
tweets but now we actually have a tweet
from Donald Trump admitting that Russia
helped to get him elected but he didn't
have anything to do with it one other
tweet I want to mention right before
Donald Trump sent these tweets he sent
another one just riddled with lies take
a look at this Donald Trump tweeting the
greatest presidential harassment in
history after spending 40 million
dollars over two years two dark years
remember that the probe ended up making
money because of all the money it
recovered from criminals with unlimited
access people resources and cooperation
which is of course wrong Donald Trump
did everything possible to avoid sitting
down with Robert Muller and ended up
providing completely bogus and
meaningless answers in writing highly
conflicted Robert Muller would have
brought charges of course no evidence of
Muller being conflicted if he had
anything but there were no charges to
bring and of course robert muller says
he cannot clear donald trump of
obstruction of justice and
Blanes the political reasons which led
to him not charging Donald Trump I still
think it's important to get all of this
stuff on the record right Trump now has
admitted in a tweet that Russia helped
him to get elected any time from now
going forward that this is called into
question let's just remember Trump has
admitted it and this will actually even
though it's very obvious to anybody
who's been observing this for the last
two years getting it on record and
having it to refer to may allow us to
short-circuit some pointless and
circular endless arguments that the
right and defenders of Trump or deniers
of reality may try to push so I get it
Trump backtracked within an hour someone
I'm sure explained to him that the the
wording implicitly suggests or says or
confirms that yes Russia helped but
Trump didn't have anything to do with it
I get that he backtracked on it an hour
later in front of his helicopter it's
still useful to get this stuff on record
as we build our case and expand the way
in which we can discuss this going
forward so major major admission from
Donald Trump unclear if he even realizes
he admitted it let me know what you
think I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the
show is on Twitter at David Pakman show
did Donald Trump understand when he put
together that tweet that he was
admitting that Russia helped but denying
he had anything to do with it
or did he not even understand that
that's what he was doing let me know
what you think today's sponsor is
Skillshare and i'm excited to tell you
that everybody in our audience is
getting two entire months of free access
to Skillshare when you click the link
underneath this video skill shares the
site that offers over 25,000 online
courses on almost any topic you can
imagine cooking meditation photography
video editing Photoshop managing a small
business almost an endless list and
whether you're trying to get ahead in
your career maybe you want to learn new
skills that will make you better at your
job you might just be exploring a new
hobby and you're trying to find new ways
to be creative in your personal time
skill shares the perfect place to fully
immerse yourself in
ever you're trying to learn I really
enjoyed the class on more advanced video
editing techniques because it's
something I've been wanting to improve
at but have been very busy hosting the
david packard show for the last few
years
once again the david pakman show is
giving you two whole months of access to
every single class offered by Skillshare
after those two months if you want to
keep your subscription Skillshare super
affordable at less than ten bucks a
month get better at whatever it is that
you're passionate about or discover
something brand new that you didn't even
know that you would love and join skill
shares other seven million users by
clicking the link underneath this video
[Music]